Good morning John!
I don't even know if you knew this about me
but I have a condition
It's called sleep paralysis
It's very common, and it's when you wake up and you can't move
This usually happens after I've had a particularly intense dream
and it's only ever a couple of seconds for me
And I woke up in the middle of the night last night after having a dream
in which Katherine got double pregnant
I don't know if you know about double pregnancy but according to my dream
anyway, it's where a woman who is already pregnant, gets pregnant again
And then there's two babies; there's an older one and a younger one
and the woman has the first baby and the other one sticks around
and she's still pregnant for even longer
which I assume is an anxiety dream
but it does actually make me wanna check something out real quick here
ahhhhhh
You can!
It's a real th- it exists!
I thought I was making a joke, you guys
It's called superfetation and it's when your body accidentally releases another egg
and then that egg gets fertilized and if it's early enough in the pregnancy
BOTH OF THE EGGS CAN BECOME BABIES
Born at the same time, but different ages gestationally
What?? What??
Aw man, double pregnant
But anyway
So I wake up from this dream, I can't move
I'm a little bit confused about where exactly I am 'cause I'm on the wrong side of the bed
But then my movement comes back
except for the first time in my life,  one arm, my right arm
does not come back
And this does not mesh with what I understand about sleep paralysis
I'm a little bit freakin' out
And I reach over to see
and here's what's happened
During my weird double pregnancy dream, I have done this
Just shoved my arm down my pants (laughing)
So that's why I couldn't move it
It was stuck in my pants
New topic now
As I was reading the comments on your most recent video
I, I noticed, I had a couple of thoughts
First, yeah, uh, our outfits
So you may have noticed, you may not have
that, uh, for two weeks in a row John and I wore the same outfits
not as each other, like, ya know the thing when you go to work the next morning and you're like
"Oh I wore this yesterday didn't I"
"That's embarassing"
Except, of course, with 250,000 people watching
There were conspiracy theories about this
that John and I had both pre-taped videos
uh, and now we're off on some secret adventure thing
No, in fact, and now it is the third week of us wearing the same outfits
The first two weeks, actually this is the case, though it seems unlikely
We did not do that on purpose
John wore the same shirt two videos in a row
I wore the same shirt and jacket two videos in a row
This week, uh, we did it just to continue messing with you
So, sorry about that
Another thing I was really struck by in the comments of your video
is how many people don't know about all the stuff that we do
And of course, because we've done a lot of things over the last 10 years
And we are currently doing a lot of things
We've got VidCon in Europe, Australia, And California coming up
We're working on a new SciShow channel with a topic to be chosen by Patreon patrons
A tenth anniversary NerdCon: Nerdfigheria to plan
A wife to kill, and Guilder to frame for it
Not actually killing my wife, that was a Princess Bride reference
Building How to Vote, continuing Dear Hank and John
occasionally Snapchatting, helping found the Internet Creators Guild
which has done a great job of explaining why the demonetization thing isn't the end of YouTube
isn't the end of everything
If you wanna read about that there's a link in the description
It reminds me, as I tend to be reminded about once a year
that I don't always understand this community as well as I could
And the first time I realized that is when we created the first Nerdfighteria Census in 2013
And I realise now that maybe I'm having this sensation because it's been another year
since there's been a Census and I haven't done another one and so
Yes! It is time!
I spent the five hours before recording this video putting together the Nerdfighteria Census for 2016
It's a pretty involved survey, there are lots of questions
We want to get a really good, deep understanding of the people in this community
so that we know better what to create, what you want from us
and what we should do together
It's hugely important to me and to John, and it's very important for this community
If you have the time to go take the Census, please please do
It's much appreciated
John, I'll see you on Tuesday
♫ Double, the pregnant, double the fun! ♫
♫ Link to the Census in the description! ♫